jennifer is in Houston Texas hi Jennifer
how are you hi Dave them great how are
you better than I deserve what's up
I'm question I want to retire early I'm
24 years old have about 26,000
retirement and I want to retire before
the age of 40 I want to ask like where
can I put my money so I can withdraw it
early without penalty and what are your
thoughts on the best ways to retire
early what does it mean to retire early
for you you stopped working and 40 if 40
you're not gonna ever work again the
rest of your life
I won't go you know to a regular day job
I might like travel or do my own thing
on the side I don't want to go to like a
workplace every day okay well I will
tell you how I have a friend that sold
his business at 31 years old for
millions of dollars and basically he
only did was play golf and fish and
after about two years he almost died
because he was he got fat and he got
completely out of control and it was not
a blessing to not have anything to do
with his life so I always challenge
folks I want you to be financially
independent so I'm with your goal but I
would have a goal of doing something at
some point and maybe it is you start
something on the side that you want to
start now before you actually have the
money to quit your job and you you know
you gross grow your business that might
be a way to go at this so but but what
would I invest in well you obviously
cannot use 401ks and Roth IRAs because
you don't have access to them without
penalty until 59 and a half right and so
I would use those as part of my wealth
building just the same but the portion
that you're going to live out of
starting at 40 if you're not going to
earn much of an income I would just go
to good mutual funds and just good
growth stock type mutual funds that
you're gonna buy and hold long term
you're gonna pay taxes on them as they
earn some portions of the income the
dividends and anything they sell so I'm
probably gonna lean towards what's
called a low turnover mutual fund okay a
good way to get that is just an S&P 500
sex fund low turnover means they don't
sell the stocks inside of the fund very
often not much turnover of the portfolio
does that make sense yeah and if they
don't sell the stocks then there's no
taxes on it until you cash it out all
right and so you'll have very little
taxation on the low turnover as you go
along until you start using the money
after age 40 so what would my plan
looked like if I were you it would be
three-pronged prong number one is I'm
probably gonna start looking for that
thing I want to do with my life I don't
want to wait off 40 I'm gonna start
working on it now that's my side deal
and start to have a small business on
the side and move towards you know what
I wanna do in my life something that's
filling and that gives me energy and so
forth and that that you know and I'm
gonna make some money with that prong to
is I am gonna do 401 K sin Roth IRAs for
the longer term but not for the 40 year
old retirement plan and then I'm gonna
do low turnover mutual funds in prong 3
something like an S&P 500 which you know
if you save substantially into that then
you should have a little bit of a nest
egg to live out of while you earn some
other income doing some other things
beginning at age 40 but I want you to
stop I mean I don't know why you work
from age 24 to age 40 at something you
hate I wouldn't my point being that I'm
56 I have no desire to retire I'm
financially set for life times 25 I mean
you know it's no issue but I have
absolutely no desire to retire and I'm
gonna work until I don't make sense here
on the air you know which some people
say is already happening but you know
I'm not only I mean I don't want to quit
I'm having fun now I what I do may
change in terms of I run this company as
a CEO everyday and that that won't be
happening when I'm 80 but I may very
well be speaking or hanging out or you
know Kelly and me'll still be arguing
you know it could still happen and so
all's we're both making sense right and
even James we might let him hang around
what do you think now we'll be back with
you before you know it folks in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one
a financial piece and that's so off
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]